Hey guys, another question that I get quite often is some of you are asking like how much should you
invest or how much should you spend in Google Ads before you give up on a deal? So first thing is
that's to me is that's the wrong mindset to have. You lose money when you quit, you lose money when
you stop. Yes there is such thing as learning and making mistakes and all that but that's why we
really emphasize hitting good due diligence, choosing the right city, choosing the right niche.
When running Google Ads there's going to be some niches that are going to be a little bit more
expensive than others. That's why we try to have a really good due diligence process and you get
a pretty good idea of that when you set up and run your, when you're setting up your Google Ad
campaign. With that being said, you know if I'm running like say like something like towing
where I need to have a lot of volume to make money, I'm going to probably spend a little bit
more money in the beginning to land a new business owner than something maybe more like landscape or
landscape design where I'm probably going to get less leads than I would for towing and I'm not
going to be spending as much on that. So that question is a little loaded where it just you
got to know your niche, you got to look at the volume. So that's why we use the data of search
volume, CPC and then we set our budget and that'll help understand like where we should be at like in
a month and stuff like that and then that'll give you that expectation of where you should be at.
Hopefully that answers that question.